konsequenzen die wir auch in diesem
koalitionsvertrag gezogen haben die
frage wie modernen stellen wir
deutschland auf und da haben wir
nachholbedarf und das muss ganz
selbstkritisch geführt werden ich bin
gegen eine kommunikation von politik
gesagt wir haben alles richtig gemacht
ich glaube wir haben vieles gut gemacht
aber wir müssen auch die kraft haben
selbstkritisch zu sagen was ein schief
gelaufen ich will ein beispiel nennen
wenn november hilfen im märz erst
ausgezahlt werden weil das wahnsinnig
lange dauert eine plattform aufzusetzen
dann stimmt was nicht mehr und jetzt gar
nicht mal ob das altmaier oder wäre es
war aber wenn man im november das als
politik beschließen und im märz kann das
ausgezahlt werden ich habe mit denen
unternehmen in meinem wahlkreis gerungen
und musste den erklären warum politik
vier monate braucht eine plattform
aufzubauen und das ist kein moderner
staat und da müssen daran deswegen
wollen wir gar nicht reden und deswegen
zu ihrer frage ich glaube sozusagen ein
learning aus corona ist doch dass wir in
der modernisierung des staates
vorankommen ist und das ist nicht das
entweder-oder ist wenn wir
digitalisierung wenn wir klimaschutz
wende staatsmodernisierung wenn wir das
nicht alles anpacken dann wachsen wir
aus dieser krise die uns ökonomisch auch
was kostet denn wachsen wir da gar nicht
raus deswegen ist die konkrete akute
pandemie bekämpfung plus ein
wirtschaftlicher stärke die durch
digitalisierung klimaschutz und
staatsmodernisierung entsteht ist der
weg raus aus dieser krise sie müssen ja
jetzt sogar gelder umschichten
die diskussion heute im bundestag haben
wir verfolgt hecklingen bei milliarden
gegen korona will die regierung jetzt im
grund höhere zwangs entfremden da muss
ich sofort radiosprecher jetzt nach
irritationen im märz übernehmen würde
sie als opposition und das nicht aus der
ruhe auch gemacht aber es ist es
besonders rechnung sind erstmal auch das
geld
eine spannende debatte weil es glaube
ich sehr jung glaubt dass ein wirtschaft
stellen über das wirtschaftsverständnis
der union aus sagt das ja sehr altbacken
ist
das geld steht zur verfügung für die
pandemie bekämpfung und die pandemie
bekämpfen wir indem wir unser land
ökonomisch stark machen indem wir aus
der krise wieder herauswachsen und was
wenn nicht also das müssen sie mir
eigentlich zustimmen wenn investitionen
in klimaschutz in digitalisierung und
werden auch gräfin doch um aus dieser
krise heraus sagen gleich noch dann
sofern ist dass an keiner stelle eine
zweckentfremdung sondern es ist ein
zeichen dass die neue regierung auf
ökonomische stärke setzt und sagt wir
wachsen sodass dieser krise das kann ich
nur sagen es fand bis vor kurzem sogar
die fdp empörend und diese fdp sei es in
persona christian lindner bei uns in der
sendung und sagte dass wenn man die die
bestehenden wegen der korona pandemie
eröffneten
kreditermächtigungen jetzt nutzt um
gewissermaßen einen vorrat anzulegen für
eine neue koalition das wäre nicht
seriös
das wäre nicht seriös es ist exakt drei
wochen die hier her klingt was haben sie
christian lindner versprochen den tisch
gezogen worden der ist über den tisch
gezogen war das sollte man mal
feststellen mal wurde immer gesagt die
grünen sind über den tisch gezogen ja es
ging doch einfach herr linder wollte
unbedingt finanzminister wäre okay
helena wollte dass man die
schuldenbremse einhält okay aber die
anderen wollen dieses programm so wie
macht man das man kann natürlich sagen
was die cdu da andere sagen wird die
höheren so viel sparen dass wir wohl
aber das klappt nie das wissen wir also
musste lindner eine position aufgeben
und das war die position des sogenannten
schatten außerhalb des haushalt wie man
dieses geld um widmet und das ist eine
die grünen die spd ich will ich sagen
wer das war ich sage nur gesagt es ist
ein
koalitionskompromiss und ich finde und
wenn man sieht was in frankreich
investiert wurde was auch in italien
investiert wird und was in spanien
investiert wird ist es völlig richtig
dass man das geld daher nimmt wo man es
nehmen kann und man kann sich streiten
ob man es hätte anders machen können
aber unstrittig ist dass dieses geld für
diese projekt absolut notwendig ist so
und dann sind wir trotzdem noch mal
dabei herrn klingen beantworten zu
lassen wie sie es geschafft haben dass
christian lindner innerhalb von drei
wochen das glatte gegenteil sagt jetzt
gibt es diesen nachtragshaushalt er
findet nicht mehr unseriös das ist eine
umwidmung der
kreditermächtigungen für die korona
pandemie gibt was haben sie ihnen
gegeben wir haben jetzt schon mehr auto
fahren wir haben in der otto
koalitionsverhandlungen sehr ernsthaft
darüber diskutiert und das war das
anliegen wie kriegen wir unser land
wirtschaftlich stark für die nächsten 10
15 20 jahre und da ist es für uns
wichtig dass der staat die
rahmenbedingungen so setzte es
investiert werden kann klar war in der
tat schuldenbremse gilt und jetzt war
die frage wie kann der staat diese
investitionen ermöglichen und nochmal
die pandemie hat uns wahnsinnig viel
abverlangt und da jetzt raus zu kommen
raus zu wachsen wirtschaftlich stark zu
werden da bietet dieser
nachtragshaushalt eine große chance und
kluger finanzminister macht das so der
finanzminister das glaube ich ziemlich
sicher sein das wäre er das nicht
sondern in der opposition und eine
regierung hätte es gemacht dass er mit
diesen worten umgehen würde
taschenspielertricks etc ja so ist
politik
deshalb ist so dass die union sich jetzt
der meinung ein stehendes letzte chance
genauso macht jetzt sagt es sind tricks
und wir gehen lassen dass yahoos
burschen habe ist es mit unter führung
der union auch gemacht bisschen vorher
da haben die gerichte gesagt das geht
nicht also es ist es ist doch so wir
brauchen uns nicht ja
in einer solchen situation
guckt der staat zum beispiel die
franzosen um zu investieren haben gesagt
wir können die maastricht kriterien
nicht erfüllen wir können nicht
frankreich schützen die französische
wirtschaft die französische menschen
alles bezahlen und die maastricht
kriterien lassen respektieren es geht
nicht dass wir sind wir können nicht das
nicht erfinden und wir müssen doch
zugeben dass in zeiten dieser pandemie
dieses traditionelle denken so nicht
mehr funktioniert sogar so dass die cdu
mit frau merkel es zugegeben hat dass
europa
gemeinsam
geld sich morgen kann das hat zwar 20
jahre unmöglich wie viel finanzminister
von herrn merz also nicht wie dann zu
dieser position da schon gekümmert er
das ja ganz europa league machen das
darf europa nicht man steht denn es gibt
ja nun auch verträge nicht und wir haben
sowohl im eu vertrag als auch im
grundgesetz ausnahmeklauseln für solche
ereignisse ja ich das und die werden das
ist auch eine ausnahmeklausel
die spannende frage wird sein ob das was
die koalition jetzt machst du das
greenwald sorry aber das ist nicht
moderne oder unmoderne
also wir sind hier hat sony das problem
im wahlkampf dass sie sie wollten genau
das schwarze null einhalten sie wollten
investitionen sind
wahr geworden sie haben alles gut sie
haben nie erklärt im wahlkampf als union
wie sieht eigentlich in kriegen wir
haben immer gesagt wir haben jetzt nein
sich das blatt verheiratet und er
sagt es mal zu ende sagen also es bleibt
auch nach dem wahlkampf richtig dieses
land hat kein geldproblem wir haben das
noch nie gehabt wir haben ein problem
dass das was gemacht werden soll nicht
schnell genug umgesetzt wird so es liegt
geld beim finanzminister und zwar in
diesem jahr im letzten jahr im
vorletzten jahr das nicht ausgegeben
werden kann wir müssen immer wieder auch
sie
sind ist es geld übrig weil bestimmte
investitionen einfach nicht auf die
straße kommt und der spannende teil bei
ihnen wird sein nicht ob sie das geld
ausgeben das werden wir am ende des
tages sehen ob sie das tun oder nicht er
wird konsequenzen geben der spannende
teil wird sein schaffen sie eine
verwaltungsmodernisierung ja eine feine
staatsmodernisierung die uns in die lage
versetzt schnell zu investieren und
diese im zum beispiel die
digitalisierung auch das thema
dekarbonisierung und digitalisierung so
zusammenzubringen das daraus schnelle
entscheidungen werden dann haben sie
unseren respekt über das geld thema
werden wir doch sehr interessant die 60
die sagen sind wir sie gar nichts doch
sie sollten nicht neu aber
selbst werden werden die auch sagen ob
da vielleicht ein bisschen aber am ende
ist der reformstau schuld denen es unter
angela merkel also dieser reformstau
liebevoller ist ein reformstau den wir
seit 25 jahren haben und in diesen 25
jahren wenn ich richtig rechne am 19
jahre die sozialdemokraten mit an der
regierung gesessen und haben sie zum
teil geführt also meinen grünen sind
unschuldig sie grüne sind auch dabei
gewesen häufig genug aber nicht so wie
diese zahl jetzt alles gut
wir haben die wahlkämpfe hinter uns
sollen jetzt gucken wir mal in der platz
mit 1022 und wenn sie sagen ihnen im
grunde egal das geld wird verwendet
werden die fragen und ist richtig
verwendet werden und rechtmäßig
aufgenommen als kredit ermächtigungen
die der staat hat aus corona und jetzt
gibt es eine gewisse akrobatik gehen
soll das was jetzt investiert werden
soll für den klimaschutz wird jetzt
kroner zugeordnet so dass der
bundesrechnungshof schon die erste
stellungnahme zu abgegeben der
bund wird es wahrscheinlich machen wir
werden darüber im parlament diskutieren
möglicherweise wird es nach karlsruhe
gehen aber das ist doch nicht die
entscheidende frage am ende des tages ob
wir uns über haushaltstitel streiten der
entscheidende punkt ist aber nicht
sicher ich bin
ja ich bleibe bei meiner festen
überzeugung auch unserer überzeugung bis
auf einige wenige ausnahmen
wir brauchen solide staatsfinanzen und
ich bin dabei gewesen kommentiert sie
wissen ist ich bin im europaparlament im
deutschen bundestag dabei gewesen als
wir den euro eingeführt haben wir haben
verträge und wir sollten uns an diese
verträge halten über frankreich könnten
da manchmal besonders nett 80
zusätzliche probleme in diesem land die
nicht gelöst werden und die haben mit
kroner gar nicht zu 480 milliarden
schulden allein durch corona die diese
neue regierung jetzt schon auf dem
zettel hat das ist eine ansage und wenn
man sich damit befassen will und muss
und das akkurat machen muss hat der
finanzminister schon mal viel zu tun das
zu verrechnen jetzt hat sich diese
regierung bettina schausten auch noch
den titel gegeben mehr fortschritt wagen
wiewohl man ja sagen muss die menschen
sehnen sich wahrscheinlich in
allererster linie danach dass es nicht
noch schlimmer wird oder dass es
vielleicht so wieder werden würde wie
früher also wie viel von dem wird von
diesem fortschritt wird überhaupt noch
möglich sein zu transportieren wenn man
sich nicht eigentlich die ganze zeit
wird und corinna kümmern das ist das
problem und das war ja noch die frage
der politischen traf ich fand ganz
interessant was herr merz gerade gesagt
hat nämlich aufs tempo verwiesen hat und
das haben sie sich ja auch vorgenommen
mehr klingen weil dass sie herr scholz
jetzt immer sagt wir müssen jetzt sehr
schnell und möglichst alles im ersten
jahr schaffen auch was die
klimaschutzpläne angeht alles im ersten
jahr und es hängt dann ja auch
tatsächlich alles mit allem zu sorgen
mehr klimaschutz mehr erneuerbare
energien hat einen wahnsinnigen
rattenschwanz an verwaltung und wann
wenn die nicht funktioniert und wenn die
digitalisierung nicht funktioniert dann
klappt das alles nicht das heißt es ist
jetzt extremer zeitdruck und von daher
finde ich die frage sehr berechtigt zu
sagen wird dass unter corona bedingungen
tatsächlich gehen oder ist nicht ihre
aufmerksamkeit jetzt
komplett dafür notwendig es muss
gelingen das ist möglich man das ist ja
das erscheint aber das muss es irgendein
aber nochmal wenn sie in den
koalitionsvertrag rhein gucken dann sind
das die richtigen grundlagen für gelegt
und das muss passieren weil die frage
zum beispiel wo wird die mobilität der
zukunft entstehen die wird jetzt
entschieden ob das in deutschland
passiert oder ob das im silicon valley
oder das in china passiert die frage die
frage wo die neuen geschäftsmodelle der
zukunft entscheidende frage wird jetzt
beantwortet und da gibt es in diesem
koalitionsvertrag und das haben wir
verabredet gibt es wahnsinnig gute ideen
im märz und ich bin völlig bei ihnen ein
großes problem in diesem land ist das
hat olaf scholz im wahlkampf sich mal
erzählt die genehmigung eines neuen
windrads dauert sechs jahre und da
müssen sechs monate kommen und das wird
diesen land aber viel abverlangen es
würden wahnsinnig viel politische
konflikte mit sich bringen aber das ist
natürlich fatal wäre diese neue und
lehrende und ich finde es ist nicht das
entweder oder sondern werden wir wollen
dass deutschland die nächsten 10 15
jahre champions league spielt ökonomisch
dann müssen diese entscheidungen jetzt
getroffen werden und ich würde mal sagen
die pandemie lehrt uns ja sogar manche
sachen man so etwas wie bei montech
zeigt doch wie ein kluges zusammenspiel
von staat und markt dazu führt dass
geschäftsmodelle der zukunft des ideen
der zukunft in deutschland entstehen
können also das ist nicht etwas wo ich
sage entweder pandemie oder die frage
wirtschaftspolitik der zukunft sondern
das ist beides und ich bin mir ganz
sicher wir kriegen das ist
hochinteressant weil wir natürlich die
gefahr ahnen herr klink bei ist es ganz
vorsichtig dass da schon wieder etwas
versprochen wird und an notiert wird was
man am ende nicht halten kann wir haben
einen ziemlich eklatanten wortbruch
jetzt jüngst erlebt nämlich in der
debatte um die impfpflicht das scheint
jetzt ein harter bruch zu sein aber er
hat ja genau diesen logischen gedanken
auch da haben politiker sämtlicher
parteien versprochen dass es so etwas
nicht kommt nämlich genau zu dieser
pflicht und am ende haben wir sie jetzt
wir haben sie jetzt für bestimmte
gruppen gleich und st alle haben und
berichtet dann mal sehen richtig ein
land aber ich wollte jetzt erstmal die
brücke mit ihnen beschreiten und fragen
wie erkundet wird das war in frankreich
wieder überhaupt kein problem
interessanter war die franzosen gehen
gern auf die straße sie gehen fiel auf
die straße deshalb man sie gesagt für
den medizinischen bereich ist die
impfpflicht eingeführt warum war es so
weniger global also also zwar gelesen
problem am rand 350.000 leute auf der
straße jetzt endlich vor 51.000 na ja
das waren also wochen lang sieben wochen
lernte sie sind diese beiden hier in
sachsen gar nichts dagegen ja also
machen wir mal wie es wohl nein aber wir
haben deswegen sagte ich die frage der
macht der zentralregierung in einer
solchen situation nämlich zu sagen da
hat der staatskrise es muss sein wir
kommen sonst nicht heil da raus und dann
hat sich das ganze volk beruhigt die
ab 12 jahre sind fast 90 prozent der
menschen geimpft wir haben ein problem
in frankreich genauso wie in andern
start 6 millionen neu die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen nicht weil sie
nicht informiert sind sondern weil sie
nicht wollen aus ideologischen gründen
rechtsradikale oder homöopathen oder
anthroposophen oder was auch immer
und das meine ich ja und ich finde in
der diskussion ist es immer ein bisschen
schwierig wenn der neue regierung
anfängt und dann sagen sie aber das wird
schwierig aber das wird schwierig ja
klar es wird schwierig und wenn sie es
nicht machen würden würde sagen ja sie
sind eine neue regierung aber sie wollen
auch gar nichts neues machen also so
können wir nicht diskutieren
es ist eine herausforderung ich kann
nicht sagen es wird klappen oder nicht
ja aber eins ist sicher corona herr merz
hat recht wenn wir nicht einen einen
digital
aufrüsten zu vermachen dann werden wir
so was wie die pandemie werden wie die
spanier das gemacht nicht machen können
oder das muss jetzt kommen ob dir jetzt
die impfpflicht kriegen oder nicht und
es lädt der letzte punkt mit der
impfpflicht sie sollten fair sein wir
haben ein gesellschaftliches problem
alle die gesagt haben es kommt keine
impfpflicht sind gutmenschen gewesen sie
haben vertraut in die vernunft der
menschen
und das würde ich niemand übel nehmen
und plötzlich stehen wir da und die
menschen sind vernünftig plötzlich
entdecken wir gutmenschen halle ich
meine minderheit ein menschen und stimme
hat er verzichtet 80 prozent der männer
sind vernünftig aber in einer pandemie
sei sind die 20 ein problem ein erster
liebt ja und plötzlich entdecken wir das
böse und dann sagen wir es gibt doch
manchmal überhaupt kein problem ich darf
besoffen nicht auto fahren da könnte man
doch immer sagen meine freiheit ich ein
liter wein ich komme aus frankreich ich
vertrage das ganz gut darum darf ich
nicht auto fahren weil du eine
gefährdung zu anderen verletzen kann
aber ist er kombiniert natürlich schon
um auch erfahrene politiker und dass sie
ich gebe ihnen recht vielleicht ist es
so alle haben gedacht jetzt haben wir
endlich den impfstoff den impfstoff aus
deutschland jetzt rennen alle hin und
lassen sich impfen das ist nicht
eingetreten
aber dann fällt natürlich eine solche
zusage es wird keine impfpflicht geben
auf die füße also hätte man das
antizipieren können ist es nicht
vielleicht doch ein bisschen zu leicht
zu sagen die waren alle so gut und
zuversichtlich und wurden dann von der
realität überholt aber
ich verstehe die angst ich verstehe die
angst vor solche pflichten aufgrund der
deutschen geschichte verstehe ich und
ich trotzdem ich hätte nie gesagt es
wird keine indem man selber aber ich
vielleicht wollen auch niemandem einen
vorwurf machen bei den politikern also
ich erklären weil sie haben ich bekomme
eine frage vorneweg sie haben gehalten
dass sie haben dazu gelernt bei dem
thema oder schlecht sie hätten auch
gerne darauf verzichtet mehr als 20 von
92 fdp abgeordneten nicht die haben
heute schon mal bei einer internen
probeabstimmung gesagt dass sie sich
gegen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
aussprechen würden
was worauf setzen sie glauben sie dass
sie dann eine mehrheit zusammenbekommen
oder brauchen sie am ende die cdu also
wenn es wenn es eine gewissensfrage ist
und wenn es die ganze region und gibt
dann ist das ja sagen nichts entlang von
fraktions linien und ich hoffe das denn
das auch der gleiche sein wird aber ich
wollte ihn ja ich habe mich häufig genug
gegen ein im cross gesprochen und ich
bekenne aus heutiger sicht war das ein
fehler so und ich finde so klar muss die
kommunikation auch sein also ich will da
gar nicht versuchen irgendwie taktisch
das zu begründen warum das jetzt so ist
ich hab mich gehört in diesem fall und
ich glaube dass politik genauso auch
kommunizieren muss in einer phase wo wir
alle ja kein masterplan haben wir alle
nicht wussten dass neue varianten kommen
wo ich ehrlicherweise nicht gedacht
hatte dass die impfquote in deutschland
so schlecht ist ich möchte hier wachsen
noch schlecht ich möchte man gleich
einzelnen ins gespräch gehen und wissen
warum lässt man sich nicht impfen ich
führe diskussion im wahlkreis wo mehr
junge frauen sagen ich lasse mich nicht
impfen weil ich angst davor haben dass
ich keine kinder bekommen kann und sagen
guckt doch bitte alle medizinischen
erkenntnisse widersprechen die ihm
gerade so nah aber dass das ist etwas wo
ich glaube wir müssen überzeugen wir
müssen und wir haben hier noch argument
wir haben unsere impfstoffe schlecht
geredet das sagt der chef dazu und
insofern aber trotzdem sehe ich doch
einfach dass wir jetzt in die vierte
welle wir sind mittendrin und die fünfte
und sechste können wir verhindern indem
wir dafür sorgen dass mehr leute geben
werden und da werde ich dann im
parlament für eine impfpflicht stimme
auch für eine allgemeine infos seien
allgemeine und dann sind wir bei anmerkt
und sagen er merkt auch sie sagen sie
haben dazugelernt würden sie auch
formulieren wie daniel cohn bendit dass
das einfach mit tatsächlich auch schade
ist und dass sie auch unterschätzt haben
wie sehr sich menschen auch ein recht
auf unvernunft herausnehmen würde ich
sagen ich bin aber noch nicht bei der
schlussfolgerung daraus die da lautet
dann müssen wir das jetzt gesetzlich
durch eine pflicht regeln
ich habe einige vorbehalte dagegen nicht
nur weil es eine erhebliche
freiheitseinschränkung ist und auch
natürlich auch eine 1 ein körperlicher
eingriff ist und damit grundrechts
relevant wie regeln wir eigentlich den
vollzug wer kontrolliert das eigentlich
wesentlich da ist möglicherweise
potenzial für die nächste große
enttäuschung wir machen das und stellen
nach ein paar wochen fest der staat kann
es gar nicht durchsetzen es ist ganz
praktisch ich will ja gar nicht legal
ist ist kommentieren aber wenn der staat
solche pflichten etabliert muss er doch
irgendwo auch gewisse gewähr haben dass
das eingehalten wird wer kontrolliert
kontrolliert
die strände der fest ob diese pflicht
eingehalten wird also ihre alkoholfahrt
wir wissen wir dass kontrolliert ja und
wenn sie heute abend betrunken nach
hause fahren müssen
dann laufen sie gefahr von der berliner
polizei angehalten zu werden ja wissen
wir das denn bei der impfpflicht auch
wird das lernen ständig wer registriert
das sind leute zu hause die gehen gar
nicht vor die tür wochen lang dürfen wir
dann bei denen mal nachfragen nur wenn
sie in free gester haben benzin- und
dann alle register oder wissen sie
werden also dass sie gerne zwei dinge
sichergestellt wissen wir wir müssen
wissen wie es im vollzug aussieht und
dann auch wirklich durchsetzen können
damit wenn ich in einem jahr hier und
die nächste enttäuschung hier öffentlich
diskutieren dass wir wieder was gemacht
haben oder eingeschätzt haben was wir
nicht erst zu kommen kann ja noch ein
zusätzliches risiko dazu dass man jetzt
möglicherweise just für den zeitraum
eine impfpflicht beschließt in der dann
eine neue variante oder es geht runter
im frühjahr eine neue variante da ist
die einen neuen
baum gesetzt also das ist nicht so
schwierig aber ich finde es geht schon
wieder darum dass man nicht genügend
impfstoff ja das ist jetzt geregelt das
hat er ja gut gemacht der hat gewarnt
und hat gleich gesagt ich habe die
lösung besser weil die masken regens
nicht so gut man hat gewann dann hat man
sie lange nicht klar es ist wahr also
schau spielerisch war das in ordnung das
war ein gummiband alle erschrocken und
dann heute gesagt kinder alles ruhig er
hat noch als ungelernt noch jemand hat
dazugelernt joshua kimmig das haben wir
verfolgt weil es natürlich nun auch ein
sehr prominentes beispiel war und das
hat er gesagt
natürlich bin ich ein vorbild trotzdem
bin ich eben nur ein mensch der eben
auch ängste und bedenken hat
und er hat noch gesagt herr kuhn wendet
man soll doch nicht auf jemanden wie ihn
dann so einen unendlichen druck ausüben
würden sie auch sagen dass das es zum
vorbild zur farbe wirkung eines
sportlers gehört sich impfen zu lassen
pappe sind stadtvierteln gegangen hat
gesagt lasst euch impfen
so nur mal um zu sagen wie man es machen
kann und alle haben das toll und andere
spieler haben das auch gemacht also ich
finde
josua chemisch soll machen was er will
es ja hab ich nicht sondern ich jemand
während lich sehr klug wie er sich
geäußert wenn er gesagt hat ich weiß
nicht punkt ich will darüber nicht reden
wäre okay gewählt er hat aber eine
begründung zuerst gegeben die er dann
muss er zurückrudern also politiker wird
immer vorgeworfen die rudern zurück und
weiter nun musste er auch zu arbeiten
und unser auftritt dann auch wieder sehr
sympathisch und
nicht
unsympathisch aber trotzdem finde ich es
gibt auch einen deutschen
handballspieler der eine die zukunft
eigentlich bedeutet da will sie sich
nicht impfen lassen der kann nicht jetzt
europameister
alle sportler die nach china wollen
politiker sollen meiner meinung nach
nicht hinfällig nomaden aber sportler
die müssen sich impfen lassen und bei
der nächsten weltmeisterschaft wird der
schuss war komisch wenn er nicht geimpft
ist kann er nicht so weltmeister und ich
finde dass die bayern oder die eintracht
einfach sagen wenn ihr nicht geimpft hat
könnt ihr nicht spielen das haben die
amerikaner in der nba gemacht ohne
probleme hoch gesetzt und hat ihn einmal
auch an ihnen sie sind grüner aus in dem
tiefsten blute die frage gibt sie
standen ja immer auch für die ergebnisse
blut sie standen natürlich immer auch
für die bürgerrechte ist das jetzt alles
und ich nur noch sache des staates
lesen sie was habermas gesagt den neuen
aufsatz wo er seine ganze öffentlichkeit
theorien nicht zurück nehmen aber in
euro gestellt sieht weil eben dieses
problem ich meine es ist nicht alles
sache des staates aber wenn leben im
spiel ist dann ist es sache des staates
leben zu schützen und wenn wir die
menschen nicht zur impfung kriegen er
dann können wir bestimmtes leben nicht
setzen und deswegen ist es nicht eine
frage der freiheit wir haben ein
gesellschaftspolitisches problem wir
müssen neu definieren die fdp muss neu
definieren ihr freiheitsbegriff sie die
hat die ganzen wahlkampf und auch jetzt
immer gesagt freiheit und herr kubicki
das ist ja unverschämt was er macht er
ist ja während dem lock down in der
kneipe gegangen hat sich rum gerührt ich
halte mich nicht daran und dann sagt er
und ich will dann natürlich auch nicht
eine impfpflicht ja was will er denn ein
klick aber andererseits wähler dass die
leute sich impfen lassen alter satz
wieder dass die menschen vorsichtig hat
mit seinem wohnort argumentiert dass da
oben niemand wirklich von dem virus
betroffen war und das ist ein scharfen
wind gibt in kiew aber so richtig toll
war es nicht und natürlich auch ein
bisschen eitel ja nee ich will nur sagen
es ist nicht alle sache des staates ist
aber in gefahr und höchster not bringt
der mittelweg den tod
und da muss man aufpassen da muss man
aufpassen weil es keine spielerei die
die politische klasse hat vielleicht zum
ersten mal seit dem krieg ganz nah etwas
gespürt war wo was nicht so existiert
hat vielleicht nach 45 die angst vor dem
tod und das hat diese pandemie gebracht
plötzlich und in italien bergamo und so
das waren bilder die wiesn ich kann die
nach 45 die spätgeborenen nicht kannten
und die meisten politikerinnen und
politiker auch nicht und deswegen finde
ich das nicht das problem ist der staat
muss alles aber in einer solchen
situation ist es die verdammte pflicht
start ist auch interessant weil die
frage sehr sofort im raum ist etwas zur
pandemie bekämpfung gut aber schädlich
für die demokratie
man hat den eindruck dass die nerven
jetzt bei geimpften die ungeimpften
blank liegen wenn man sich anschaut was
auf den deutschen straßen los ist auf
einem teil der deutschen straßen
vielleicht gucken wir uns das noch mal
magdeburg am vergangenen montag nach
zwei jahren corona politik entlädt sich
der frust auf der straße überall
proteste dass hier die leute in panik
und angst versetzt werden über zwei
jahre fast zwei jahre also ich finde es
unbegreiflich dass die leute ihren job
verlieren es werden ja wirklich die
geimpften gegen die ungeimpften wirklich
auseinander dividiert die einen
aufgebrachte bürger anthroposophen im
skeptiker andere verschwörungs gläubige
starts verächter oder rechtsextremisten
die polizei muss wie hier in mannheim
verbote durchsetzen gegen immer
aggressiver werdende demonstranten
die teilnahme an diesem aufzug ist eine
straftat weil der aufzug verboten ist
wenn fackelzüge vor politiker häuser
ziehen oder corona leugner auf telegramm
ort pläne schmieden wird protest zur
gefahr eine lange unterschätzte gefahr
wie erst kürzlich in dieser sendung
deutlich wurde
diese telegramm gruppen diese
rechtsextremen gruppen von 30-40 80.000
menschen die sich zusammengetan haben
und bösartigste propaganda
hetze aber auch wirklich zersetzende
dinge programmieren wir müssen da etwas
tun das geht so nicht das muss nicht
falsch seien aber andere dinge sind
natürlich dringende die politik schaut
bislang hilflos zu wie rechte gruppen
auf telegramm protest und gewalt
organisieren doch telegram schützt ihre
anonymität
herr klingbeil jetzt müssen wir wieder
ein bisschen ordnen einige dieser gegner
der korona politik brauchen den
staatsanwalt mit vielen anderen so sagen
sie wollen sie reden
also nicht mit denen die jetzt mit
fackeln vor die häuser von politiker
marschieren oder mit denen die auf
telegramm mordpläne das sind auch das
ist auch keine debatte über corona
sondern das sind rechte hetzer die
diesen staat ersetzen wollen die suchen
sich sonst irgendein anderes thema und
ich finde der mut den einwand dass
beschreibt also das hat nichts mit
debatten über cola zu tun was wir gerade
erleben ich diskutiere mit denen die
angst haben vor dem impfstoff ich
diskutieren mit denen die fragen stellen
und diese fragen müssen auch erlaubt
sein die müssen wir beantworten als
politik- oder als medizin aber das war
in den letzten nächten eigentlich
antworte durch debatte ich antworte
dadurch dass ich diskussionsangebot in
meinem wahlkreis mache aber nochmal wenn
jemand mit fackeln vor die wohnhäuser
von politikern marschiert wenn jemand
versucht politische konkurrenz
einzuschüchtern wenn jemand mord pläne
schmiedet dann braucht es eine harte
antwort des rechtsstaates und das hat
nichts mit politischen mit wem lohnt es
sich zu reden mit wem lohnt es sich zu
streiten und wie lange kann man zuhören
und verständnis haben oder sind wir
schon bei denen die sagen es gibt eine
tyrannei der ungeimpften also im grunde
genommen erpressen die ungeimpften die
geimpften wie der welt eher zu wünschen
man gerät ist nein ich formuliert zu
solch drastischen begriffen würde ich
nicht greifen weil ich noch mal weil ich
ja auch wirklich weiß aus politischen
diskussion dass es viele gibt die auch
dabei sind sich zu überzeugen gerade
noch und dann möchte ich gerne als
politik helfen dass man sich dann auch
überzeugt sich impfen zu lassen aber wir
erleben gerade eine kleine sich
radikalisierenden gruppe die gezielt
auch diese aktuelle situation nutzt um
gegen den staat zu agieren und gegen das
gemeinwohl und den zusammenhalt in
diesem land zu ergeben und da darf es
kein falsches verständnis von
von von zuneigung geben oder von
verständnis oder von politischer debatte
das halte ich für ein riesenfehler
wir sind bettina chancen bei der frage
dass es im grunde bei allen großen
gesellschaftlichen entscheidungen
politischen entscheidungen ja gegenwehr
gegeben hat von minder werden von
minderheiten egal was ist los und
minderheiten egal ob es die ostpolitik
war ob es die euro-einführung die
deutsche einheit war es gab immer auch
protest was ist jetzt bei dieser art des
protestes anderes
das ist jetzt ein ganz großer bogen also
350.000 sind es ja hier tatsächlich
nicht und von daher wenn man den o-ton
noch mal nimmt die ungeimpften gegen die
geimpften ausspielen ist ist da würde
ich mit olaf scholz gehen keine spaltung
jedenfalls keine spaltung in dem sinne
dass wir 50 50 hätten sondern wir haben
in der tat eine minderheit und da wo sie
eben gewaltbereit ist und extremistisch
ist glaube ich muss tatsächlich das eine
harte antwort finden ist das in sachsen
ich will das mal aufnehmen und ich würde
ausdrücklich gern noch mal sagen wollen
da sind natürlich nicht nur idioten
sondern weil sie vorhin das so mal eben
in den raum werfen ihm aber
vor 390 jahr zudem debatte dadurch so
ein gedanke
wenn ich das noch sagen da
was ist da jetzt in sachsen los ich
glaube schon wir sind so ein bisschen
darüber hinweggegangen das natürlich
jetzt so eine diskussion über die
impfpflicht dazu führt dass die leute
sich bestätigt fühlen so nach dem motto
sie wussten wir doch jetzt kommt eben
doch und das ist natürlich fatal
das heißt das weiter an und macht es
vielleicht augen das war die frage macht
noch mal schwierig ist es geht jeden
existenziell an es ist in gleicher weise
es steht die die eigene körperliche
unversehrtheit
zur debatte es geht nicht um geld es
geht um wirklich genial aber deshalb
lässt es sich auch wahrscheinlich
besonders gut von extremisten geben
und das ist die ganze russische farben
eher märz frage dazu zu sagen menschen
nicht verloren zu geben den kontakt
wieder herzustellen zu ihnen seitens des
staates das ist uns schon mal bei peggy
der nicht gelungen also mit diesem
hintergrund auch denkend was glauben sie
mit leben redet man ja also ich würde
den vergleich nicht gerne ziehen weil
ich finde das sind schon ganz
grundlegende unterschiede wenn man die
beiden frauen x mal anhört die da gerade
in diesem film vorkam es dauert einfach
mittlerweile zu lange nicht mehr wir
sind jetzt im zweiten jahr
viele familien sind am anschlag mit
ihren möglichkeiten die kinder gehen
nicht regelmäßig in die schule beruflich
geht das schwierig finanziell wird das
schwierig also das ist eine solch ein
solcher stress für diese gesellschaft da
glaube ich kann man schon verständnis
für viele haben die dann einfach mal
sagen ich bin einfach total leid und und
die würde ich gerne sorgfältig trennen
von denen die diese stimmung im land
missbrauchen für solche gewalttätigen
demonstrationen und
einschüchterungsversuche und wir haben
eben leider mittlerweile fast
ausschließlich im rechtsradikalen
bereich gruppen die sich solche themen
zu eigen machen und daraus dann auch
solche gewalt reaktionen reden wir auch
noch
gesondert noch mal es ist ja auch so ein
völlig dispens publikum eigentlich da
sind ja dann ja kommentiert hat gesagt
da sind familienväter dabei da sind
anthroposophie da sind heilpraktiker
dabei und eben auch rechtsextreme ganz
gut ich glaube ich dass wir noch mal
sagen wenn jedenfalls diejenigen die
ärzte sind sehr sorgfältig wägen was sie
sagen also wenn ärzte zum beispiel ich
habe das jetzt zwei dreimal in
telefonaten mit familien gehört dass
ärzte abraten sich jetzt impfen zu
lassen ärzte abraten kinder zu impfen
also bitte man muss glaube ich auch mal
an die ärzte appellieren achten sie ein
bisschen darauf weil sie die wirkung
ihrer äußerungen vor allem wenn sie dann
öffentlichen erfolgen mir ist
mittlerweile in der öffentlichen debatte
eine zu große dass man wirklich so wie
es meine kakophonie es geht ein bisschen
zu viel durcheinander und dann nimmt man
sich raus was man gerade gerne er war
hören möchte und hat angst so angst ist
natürlich ein ganz schwerer gegner in
seiner solchen commission richtig
nochmals um diesem publikum auf der
straße oder zu diesen demonstranten in
den alten bundesländern darauf wollten
sie wahrscheinlich verweisen auch vor
allen dingen hier in deutschland ist
diese impfskepsis hat die in die
tradition sie hat auch tradition in
einem über er sehr liberalen linken auch
an dem anthroposophischen milieu also es
müsste der fairness halber ja dazu
gehören nicht immer nur in diese rechte
ecke zu schauen ja anderen zu sagen wir
sind ideologisch verbohrte
unterschiedlich ideologisch eingemauerte
ich kenne
anthroposophen oder homöopathen oder
anhänger der homöopathie
man kann nicht mehr mit ihnen
diskutieren und nicht weil sie nicht
informiert sind sondern sie haben zu
jede information nein und das ist die
das ist das problem ich glaube sie haben
gesagt sie können verstehen die leute
die satt haben ich kann verstehen die
leute die diese diskussion satt haben
weil sie sagen wir wissen das doch ich
kann es nicht also ich persönlich
habe noch nicht ein argument gehört und
wenn sie von rtl warum sollen ärzte
schlauer sein als andere menschen ja
aber nur weil ich mir wirklich in der
öffentlichkeit eine autorität ja und das
ist schlimm und deswegen glaube ich wenn
der staat und es die impfpflicht ist
auch etwas wo der staat evident
wissenschaftliche evidenz basierte
politik auch durchsetzen wir durch die
endlich sagen die ende der debatte und
man kann das nicht mehr infrage stellt
genauso wie man krebs nicht infrage
stellen kann und man kann krebs nicht
heilen mit lutschbonbons ja das geht
nicht ja übrigens in einer ich will dass
man sei in einer situation entscheiden
wir über die frage der im
pflichtprogramm chemotherapien abgesagt
werden wo lebensnotwendige operationen
verschoben werden das ist ja der kontext
in dem eher antik entscheidet und herr
merz ich glaube wir verstehen uns ja
nicht falsch aber ich finde es gibt dann
irgendwann auch den punkt wo man sagt
ich diskutiere da jetzt nicht ja ja bei
den frauen definitiv aber auch die
müssen ja wissen was es bedeutet wenn
man sich in rheydt in fackelzüge da ist
dann ob ich das ist ja verständlich denn
da ist eine grenze überschreiten und ich
glaube da gab es zu viel falsches
verständnis aufgewachsen ist selbst
eingeredet worden mit solchen leuten ja
der hat polizei zugehört polizei nicht
eingegriffen und und da sind sachen
zugelassen wurden wird man viel früher
für den ort und dennoch noch mal die
frage also im grunde ist die demokratie
ja auch deshalb eine so schätzwerte
gesellschaft weil sie minderheiten
schützt vor dem durchgriffsrecht einer
mehrheit
und wir sind schon mal aufgefordert
gewesen da ist der vergleich leider
wieder da dass wir das auf
demonstrationen man sich kenntlich
machen soll als nicht zu den rechten
zugehörig als es damals in die
flüchtlingskrise ging wie soll man das
praktischerweise denn machen wenn man
ein demonstrationsrecht ausüben ja aber
man muss schon wissen mit wem man zieht
und den man hinterherläuft und welcher
flagge man folgt das glaube ich kann man
von jedem dann auch verlangen und ich
glaube schon man muss sich die situation
sehr gut angucken läuft da was aus dem
ruder das hat man ja im moment ändern
dieses gefühl also diese große zahl von
kommunalpolitikern die die angefeindet
werden
fackelzüge aufmärsche vor politiker
häusern
journalisten die auf offener straße
angespuckt werden etc also da passiert
ja gerade etwas heute gab es den fall
dass ein lka beamter des sächsischen
landeskriminalamts
aufgeflogen ist quasi weil er wiederum
in privat als privater demonstrant
niedersächsischen bereitschaftspolizei
angegriffen hat da gab es eine
schlägerei also was da passiert und es
war nicht wegen ja nicht weil er nicht
wusste der
und da in der tat muss man glaube ich
sehr sehr hartes und klares zeichen
setzen und da kommt man dann eben auch
mit ärzten die sagen lass dich impfen
nicht mehr weiter dass man vom staat
alles erwartet und ihn auf der anderen
seite gleichzeitig verachtet wie geht so
was glauben sie erklärt dass man vom
staat alles er war ja
das zeigt vielleicht die paradoxie
dieser zeit so nochmal jeder muss wissen
was er da tut und das ist nicht aufgabe
des staates das den menschen zu erklären
sondern das merkt jeder selbst in
welchem umfeld fällt er dann bei den
demonstranten noch ein bisschen größer
in bezug natürlich auf die menschen die
tatsächlich einen echten zweifel haben
hier in diesem fall ist es so dass man
es mit starts verachten zu tun hat da
sie völlig recht und auf der anderen
seite gibt es die riesige
erwartungshaltung sie daran an dieser
situation etwas zu verändern
friedrich merz hat gesagt er würde so
gerne schaffen die afg zu halbieren
diesen gedanken noch mal aufnehmend ist
es möglich tatsächlich ein anderes
alternative politikangebote zu machen
oder ist politik in dieser pandemie
alternativlos diese
alternativlos ist in der demokratie
nichts und niemand
ich habe das mit der afg vor drei jahren
gesagt ich wiederhole das seit geraumer
zeit nicht mehr weil ich sehe wie sich
diese partei weiter radikalisiert und
großenteils nicht mehr ansprechbar ist
was mich in dieser ganzen diesen fehler
es war eindeutig damals richtig aber
drei jahre sind vergangen und ich sehe
sie jetzt im parlament und sehe wie sie
sich dort verhalten und das so aber es
ist etwas anderes was mich beschwert ich
merke dass bei leuten die mit der fdp
nicht zu tun haben die wirklich aus dem
tiefsten bürgertum dieses landes tun
bekommen sich plötzlich in ihrer sprache
verändern und immer eine art und weise
über dieses land über politiker über
politische entscheidungen über die
institutionen reden die kommen hier nach
berlin situierte leute sitzen in der s
bahn ich treffe die da und anpöbeln die
da herum das sind erkennbar gut
situierte bürgerliche leute teilweise
ehepartner freundeskreise die dann hier
nach berlin kommen und hier
demonstrieren ist ihr gutes recht sollen
sie gerne machen aber die sprache die
dabei geübt wird die muss ich sagen die
stört mich wirklich und da haben wir es
nicht nur mehr mit kleinen gruppen zu
tun sondern das ist ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches phänomen das
wir hier in diesem land offensichtlich
eine gewisse entgrenzung in der art und
weise wie wir miteinander reden haben
und unter der ich meine der
bundeskanzler hat das finden finde ich
richtigerweise gesagt dass auch respekt
mal vor auch der meinung von anderen
hier wieder notwendig ist ich hoffe dass
wir das hinbekommen auch gemeinsam in
dem auch die parlamente auch die
abgeordneten da ein stück vorbild in der
art und weise wie sie politische
diskussionen führen sind sonst kommen
wir da noch mehr in solche konflikte
hinein und das muss noch nicht das ende
sein was wir über eingeladen länger zu
dicht und das sage ich ohne jede polemik
an der stelle bin ich wirklich froh dass
nicht mehr die afg die stärkste
oppositionskraft in deutschland da bin
ich völlig beiden glauben dass solche
politischen kultur gut tut weil man auch
unterschiede deutlich machen kann und
das zweite ist aber ich wir reden sie
haben jetzt von gruppen gesprochen die
zweifelsohne da sind aber wir reden zu
wenig von denen die uns seit zwei jahren
helfen vernünftig durch diese pandemie
durchzukommen mit viel solidarität mit
miteinander die machen alles mit die
lassen sich impfen die halten sich an
alle regeln und die sind auch frustriert
gerade weil sie im ziel dass andere sich
nicht daran halten und gerade auch die
tür gebracht ein stückweit bestimmt
wieder ein interessanter punkt das
geschieht in dieser sendung sehr wohl
und dennoch die frage gibt eine kluge
soziologen die hat gesagt wir haben alle
miteinander die
geduld verloren wir sind seit zwei
jahren in diesem dauer krisen modus wenn
man es noch größer denkt eigentlich seit
der eurokrise finanzkrise
flüchtlingskrise jetzt krone krise und
man hat im doppelten sinne das gefühl
dass wir nicht vor die welle kommen
sondern dass wir immer hinter der bälle
sind
was glauben sie tut man gegen dieses
gefühl getriebener zu sein egal ob man
politiker ist oder normaler bürger oder
auch journalist ist ich glaube und dass
es der fehler aus den letzten monaten
von über den wahlkampf geredet wo das
team nicht die rolle gespielt hat die
täter haben müssen sich jetzt bewusst zu
machen das wird noch lange andauern und
wir haben noch lange mit diesem virus
werden also auf die sich das bewusst zu
machen ist die antwort darauf
es wird nicht in zwei wochen in vier
wochen sechs wochen vorbei sein sondern
ist dauert es gibt heißt aber übersetzt
es gibt keine garantien es gibt keine
gewissheiten und wir sollten auch nicht
mehr sagen dass wir mit gewissheit dann
und dann durch die pandemie durch sind
sagte es werde ist werde ich nicht mehr
aussprechen
und genau darin bettina schausten läge
dann die gefahr dass man wieder neue
gewissheiten formuliert und wieder neue
hoffnungen ja also es ist so mit der
geduld da mangelt ist und also ich würde
gerne auch der politik zu gestehen
lernen zu sein und sie haben es ja auch
ausgedrückt in ihren jedenfalls in der
vorstellung des koalitionsvertrages also
lernen zu sein was ich aber wirklich
erwarte ist dass fehler nicht zweimal
gemacht werden und das habe ich ja und
ich noch in den sommer und das und
nichts versprechen was man nicht halten
kann ich nehme wahr es gibt einzelne
beispiele ich hatte zum beispiel
interview mit der familienministerin der
die ich nach einer impfpflicht für
kinder fragte können sie das denn
ausschließen und die schlaf nicht mehr
aus wenn das so zu sagen dann jetzt auch
mal lerneffekt ist dann finde ich das
finde ich das in ordnung also ich glaube
die erwartung muss man haben und wir
sehen schon und das ist auch eine
selbstkritik an meinen meinen eigenen
berufsstand diese regierung die neue ist
eine woche im amt können also früher hat
man den mal 100 tage wieder bei und
jetzt sind sie nach sieben tagen
natürlich dran und die hat sich selber
aber auch zu wort gemeldet ohne der
serien im amt oder muss man vielleicht
da auch noch dazu sagen sie hatte sich
zu wort gemeldet opposition herr merz
wir alle gucken auf den morgigen tag 14
uhr dann wird ein ergebnis ausgezählt
bis heute durften die mitglieder der cdu
entscheiden wen sie zum zukünftigen
vorsitzenden haben wollen wissen sie
schon was hat sich schon jemand
angerufen wir wissen dass wir eine sehr
hohe wahlbeteiligung haben 64 prozent
das ist sensationell fast zwei drittel
der cdu mitglieder haben von dieser
möglichkeit gebrauch gemacht und das
gibt mir wenn ich das sagen darf ein
gewisses maß an zuversicht und
optimismus dass wir ein gutes
wahlergebnis haben sie ist schon
verraten nein ich kann es nicht ich weiß
es nicht und wir haben auch verabredet
dass wir es erst um viertel vor zwei
also wenige minuten bevor wir dann in
die presse gehen erfahren und das ist
ein verfahren und dass wir uns auch alle
halten es gibt wahnsinnig viel zu denken
es sind große aufgaben würden sie immer
noch sagen die cdu ist denkfaul oder
würde sie es wollen wir jetzt auch
gemeinsam ändern
ich möchte nur eine lanze für das
deutsche system brechen nämlich ich
finde dass in deutschland das die
parteien koalieren können und wenn man
die grünen und die fdp sieht und früher
die grünen und die cdu das ist in einem
land wie frankreich und möglich und da
ist die ebene der politischen debatte
noch hasserfüllte unter den partei nicht
nur in der bevölkerung von amerika oder
in amerika deswegen es sei aber in
deutschland nicht möglich heisst sie nur
wäre in deutschland nicht mehr vor allem
vor allem ist in frankreich eine
koalition zwischen grüne und fdp oder
grüne und cdu oder was auch immer nicht
möglich das heißt es läuft vieles
schlecht in deutschland aber die
politische kultur ist besser als es
manchmal hier in den talkshow und
verkaufen will also wir haben gar keinen
hass wir wünschen uns sogar dass hier
mehr
man hat ein gutes beispiel abgegeben
ehrlich wir haben einen friedlichen
regierungswechsel in diesem land erlebt
was wir nun für westliche demokratien
auch nicht mehr selbst verstehen genau
übrigens auch da soll man lernt kurve
bei mir ich bin früher ein anhänger des
mehrheitswahlrechts gewesen das geht
aber nur wenn es eine stabile politische
mitte gibt die gibt es nicht mehr und
deswegen bewährt sich im augenblick das
deutsche verhältnis war genau das in
frage weil ich nicht haben was in
amerika nicht haben
das nicht sprengt gesellschaft
auseinander und jetzt sind wir in der
lage in unserem politischen system das
wenigstens einigermaßen noch zusammen zu
aber sein großer vorteil auch wenn
volksparteien keine volksparteien mehr
sind das war's profilen wir mal beim
nächsten mal wirklich vorsitzender
unbedingt
freundschaft ist darf mich ganz herzlich
bedanken weil diese runde heute abend
danke fürs nicht nur dabei sein sondern
vor allen dingen mit denken es ist
unsere letzte sendung lebe zuschauer wir
sehen uns wenn sie mögen am 13 januar
wieder das ist noch ein bisschen hin
jetzt gleich im programm folgt markus
lanz der unter anderem bodo ramelow zu
gast hat und was wir ihnen was ich ihnen
wünsche denken sie sich bleiben sie halt
irgendwie kommen sie gut durch diese
tage die hoffentlich besinnliche tage
und tage echter muse sind und dann bis
2022 vielen dank
[Musik]